trappes et long cours la verrière ou
encore le mesnil saint denis et saint
cyr l'école la 11e circonscription des
yvelines recense plus de 115 mille
habitants une population hétérogène qui
en juin 2012 portée benoît hamon au
poste de député avec plus de 55% face au
sortant jean-michel fourgous maire
d'elancourt cinq ans plus tard le
socialiste aura occupé deux postes de
ministres et défendu les couleurs de son
parti à la présidentielle
son score à fragiliser sa position
puisque dans la commune de trappes où il
aura siégé quelques temps en tant que
conseiller municipal jean luc mélenchon
et la france insoumise réalisé à ce
scrutin un meilleur résultat face à un
benoît hamon affaibli jean michel
fourgous vice-président de saint-quentin
entend retrouver un poste qu'il occupait
de 1993 à 2002 seulement lui aussi doit
faire face à une difficulté
l'échec de françois fillon lors de la
présidentielle le candidat des
républicains s'est placée 3e dans sa
propre commune derrière notamment
emmanuel macron pour ces législatives ce
dernier est représenté par une candidate
de la société civile nadia et qui
espèrent profiter d'une vague en marche
au niveau national au total treize
candidats se présentent dans la 11e
circonscription la gauche elle part
divisée avec les candidatures
supplémentaires du parti communiste de
lutte ouvrière ou encore du npa
de son côté le front national et et sa
conseillère régionale mathilde andrew et
doivent faire face à la candidature du
front libéré à partie formée après
l'exclusion de militants favorables à
jean marie le pen principaux enjeux dans
cette circonscription l'éducation et
l'avenir entre autres des rythmes
scolaires défenseurs de la mesure benoît
hamon fait face à jean-michel fourgous
qui entend revenir à une semaine de 4
jours en profitant de la volonté d'
emmanuel macron de laisser plus de
liberté aux communes
la sécurité est aussi au coeur du
scrutin plusieurs faits divers ont
écorné l'image de ce secteur
60 à 80 je n'aurais qui tetra pour la
syrie ces derniers mois